Why cancer is amino acid base? So I think you're talking about what's feeding your cancer?
Well, it depends on how that was tested who tested that and when that was tested. So if
Originally you got tested through me, and it was your cancer was fed more through amino acids
that
It's made in how many years and then your cancer's changed. So
That's why you do another cheek swab test because fuel sources of your cancer changes
So again, if you were like stable and you were doing great and you're doing fantastic, then I don't know that you should really change
Anything you're doing or not make any drastic changes
but if the cancer is growing it's it's you know moved from dormancy to stability or you know
We're doing you know pretty well to down up to it very well
Then that's where you have to get some re-checked out and see what's going on